what do you think when people say things
like lease option agreement there'll be
a thing of the past in no time
it would never stand up in court and
really poopoo the idea of doing the
lease option agreement as a solicitor
that does Lease Option agreements what's
your response my response is lease
options have been around for a very very
long time they're not new it's
relatively new to residential property
there isn't it it's very very common in
commercial property so I don't see them
disappearing overnight certainly if the
property market has a little downturn
with with brexit then they'll become
even more important as people have
negative equity they're extremely
powerful tool when there is negative
equity there's less there's less reason
to have them when isn't it when there's
plenty of it but there's a lot of next
lecture at the moment in parts of the
north yes what about when people say
that they won't stand up in court
surely you've seen you've seen that
happen maybe I certainly have
and when seller has legal representation
then there is no reason that it
shouldn't stand up in court if it's an
inappropriate deal for the seller and
the sellers have legal representation
the sellers recourse would it be against
their lawyer not the validity of the
agreement so basically people that say
they don't work they don't work stand up
in court there are going to be a thing
of the past soon really a talking from a
position of ignorance rather than a
logical standpoint probably because they
haven't got any themself they can't find
the deals and they're just trying to
bring down anybody else's tower yes and
and so they are risky deals and that's
why when we are advising on lease
options we take the time yeah the care
with clients to ensure that they know
what they're doing you know what the
what the deal means to them and the deal
makes sense to them and if we don't feel
it'd be a win-win fit it's gotta be I've
seen so many of my students do starting
with very little money or no money and
then they built their portfolio if I
went to rent lease option agreement so I
think when people say
doesn't work there right it doesn't work
for them absolutely what do you think
about lease option agreements then your
but your solicitor and you signed lease
option agreement you write up the
documents all the time for them yeah
that's something that you would consider
ever doing yourself and if so why I have
done them yeah I have done them myself
it's not something that I actively go
and search out because I've always had
I've always been able to fund a property
that I want yeah and I guess if I'd if
it wasn't the Liebherr practice I
probably wouldn't have been able to fund
the properties I want because I'd have
wanted more properties well as it
happens you're in a position where
you've got quite a lot of money which is
great because you happen to buy
properties early you've had a successful
business if you have the lease option
agreement but you can see that there are
very viable ways to get by problems
about using any Romani I from a personal
perspective I use options more for
developments yeah yeah absolutely July
sale sale people like people like
Alastair and in fact his his deal was he
wasn't so good you could argue that you
actually told the vendor to change the
terms right yeah I know instead said I
says it to me he said you know when you
when you said that Sam Watkins Reid is
there to look after the coin he really
is isn't it you know tell me a bit about
that we take our job very seriously a
lot of firms most firms will look at
look at a lease option sorry its most
residential conveyance of solicitors
will look at a lease option they won't
be familiar with it they'll consider it
to be very risky tell our clients not to
do it they don't know how to advise on
the risk and it doesn't go anywhere
yeah then you've got commercial
solicitors that are used to dealing with
complex leases and option agreements and
their and their fees will be prohibitive
to doing it on residential property so
there is us being one of them this group
of solicitors and specialist property
lawyers that are providing
a relatively economical service for
investors and people that would choose
through these kind of deals what do I
think about them there is certainly
scope for abuse and I have seen
instances where there has been some
abuse of position abuse as in taking
advantage of vulnerable clients people
doing the wrong kind of deal so when
when we're assessing a deal when it when
a client when someone comes to us and
they wants us to advise on it we will
look at it and say does this deal make
sense for this person is it a win-win
is it a win-win yeah it's a fair deal
for the client and if it is and they
want to do it we want to help them yeah
to do that deal because there are
investors of course that will try and
hoodwink old ladies and get them and
that's of course the reason that it's a
good idea from an investor's point of
view to make sure that the vendor is
legally represented absolutely as if
they're not legally represented not only
what could you unfairly take advantage
of them but down the line if it goes to
a court of law the judge will clearly
look at it and say well they weren't
legally represented it was an unfair
deal but if they'll be represented
fairly it's been a win-win then that
also puts security for the investor
absolutely in a nice option typically an
investor will take it on let it out pay
a mortgage and make a very small profit
each month and out of that profit they
may have you know a lot a large expense
that they weren't expecting all sudden
they've got no profit yeah and so in a
lease option and the money is made by
exercising the option more often than
not the capital appreciation and
appreciation and so if the seller didn't
have legal representation and it's an
unfair deal yeah and let's face it your
average option isn't your average option
is very much in the buyers favor because
it's the buyers choice to buy yeah the
seller has an obligation if they're
asked to but then you can put your life
things like penalties for that you can't
can also put in place what I often do is
you'll give them your intent 12 months
prior to completion so there are things
you can do to make it more of a win-win
yes there can be a premium and you know
for it for it for instance premium might
be motivated Saturday perhaps they've
got mortgage arrears and the mortgage
company's taking action
they've got 5,000 pounds of mortgage
arrears so the premium might be 6,000
pounds let's say so there's 5,000 plans
to pay off the arrears plus a thousand
plans to cover legal costs yeah some
people some people just don't want to be
landlords anymore or they don't yeah but
swampert anymore they were negative
equity they can't sell it yeah and they
are desperately happy to just pass that
father's you understand below not not
not just happy it is the best outcome
that they could possibly have because no
no buyer in their out and the right mind
is going to buy that property yeah and
that that that owner is desperate to get
out the situation and I I don't I don't
see any other viable way of them having
a win-win deal yeah so they're certainly
so there certainly is a place for lease
option agreement and also from what's in
it for the for the buyers point of view
well from the buyers point of view and
going back to my situation when I was
buying properly when I was building up
my keep portfolio if you like yeah and I
was in a position to buy not everyone is
in a position to buy like a financed
lack of finance but but even myself and
I would commit to buy a property and I
didn't always have all the finance
together correct you don't have to go
and find the finance and and and if you
haven't got the means to get that
financed with your financial credibility
the money behind you your contacts so to
ask for private finance the relationship
with with lenders then lease options
mean that you can enter into these deals
with a limited amount of money it always
costs something even if it's legal fees
or whatever a small premium perhaps
some work to do on the property when
you've taken it on perhaps you could
have cover the mortgage before you've
actually got it let you normally need a
little bit of money yeah so there's
nowhere near the amount that you'd need
to put down a wealthy house nowhere near
yeah and so it enables anybody that
really wants to if they really go for it
if they if they can build the right read
relationships right credibility that
anybody can build a property portfolio
using lease options yeah starting with
very very little money yes that's
fantastic thank you so much for watching
if you benefited from that video please
do share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time